okay welcome to the round three recap uh
in this one I played Isaac Wayne and the
game finished about an hour ago it was
the longest game of the round like we
were the last players in the room uh
game was uh I think over four and a half
hours and it was just a marathon really
tired but I have some aloe juice to
hopefully keep me slightly awake and
hydrated
so anyway
um going into this game I found some of
my opponents online games
um he's a pretty young player I think 13
or 14 years old and uh he drew his first
two games I saw in this round two game
he played a perfect game like no
mistakes no inaccuracies no blunders so
I knew I was probably playing an
underrated uh player here and um yeah
before the game I decided that I would
play the English opening on move one
which I did
and then he surprised me because in most
of his online games and some tournament
games I saw he's playing the move Pawn
C6 but he surprised me with the move
Pawn E5 which I don't think I came
across any games where he's played this
move before
um but thankfully I've had experience
over the years playing the English and I
was just following my repertoire played
my C3
and then he played a move which made me
chuckle a little bit he played the move
Bishop to B4 and the reason why I
thought this was kind of funny is
because I had the same position in my
round two game except colors were
flipped and the move H5 would be thrown
in uh just to show my round two game uh
this is the position I have in round two
against Grand Master Daniel Fernandez so
as a very similar opening but it's a bit
more mainstream like this is this is a
bit more theoretical with a Pawn on each
seven and knots on each five
and I was trying to figure out what to
do here because I assumed Isaac would
have seen my round two game and so I
played the queen move uh in the opening
and maybe he would be prepared for it it
subjectively not the best approach uh
the best move here is Knight D5 this is
the main line but I was trying to figure
out a different move to play to just
avoid any potential preparation he could
have done and ultimately I decided on
the Move Pawn to G3 and the reason why I
played this is because I've been
studying the Sicilian and more
specifically the russellimo Sicilian
from the black side and this is
essentially a rosalimo but up a tempo
for me
um and yeah it's uh a lot of the lines
are kind of natural developments and I
thought that maybe going into this it
would be a bit outside my opponent's
comfort zone and preparation so game
continues I have six Bishop G2 Castle
meta3
um and then he plays E5 which is I think
a very playable move and I'm pretty sure
we're still following Theory
um yeah there's been a over 100 games in
this position in the Masters database
but I I don't know if I've ever checked
this line specifically
um many years ago when I was first
learning the English I have a book by
Anatoly karpov like he wrote a whole
book on English not quite a repertoire
book but it's a collection of games and
covering major lines and I had very
vague memories of karpov discussing this
sign but I was pretty much on my own I
played the move Knight D4
he played rookie eights and then I
Castle now I do want to actually make
the points and I'll go on an interesting
tangent because
um this line is very common with reverse
colors and I just want to show an
interesting Nuance imagine it's a
rosalimo Sicilian
and we go into the same thing that uh
was just playing uh Castle
it's a pure and then rookie one here
here here so this is the same position
except white now has a move and there's
a line here Knight C3 Knight C7
takes
D takes 94 B6 and then Knight F6 check
and this is actually the famous game
between uh Carlson and Hans Neiman it's
the game that Hans won in just a
beautiful Masterpiece from the lock side
and then he gave that famous interview
where he said chess speaks for itself so
I was remembering the opening in that
game and going back to the position that
we have here if black has a move black
can play Knight here here and we
essentially get the same line but
reverse but because it's White's move
I'm in time to Castle and black has no
time to get this cool and I have three
idea so I thought at the very least
white should be equal like especially
given that White's able to Castle before
blackouts any substantial initiative now
I was still like out of my uh specific
prep but at least I I remembered some
small tidbits from um from a different
but similar opening
so going forward here Knight C6 Knight
C2 and we do enter this uh imbalance
after takes takes and then yeah just to
show if 95 B3 because I'm Castle there's
no Knight F3 uh so my opponent played D6
here
and then from here it's a slightly weird
structure because black does have more
space but I have the bishop pair and
some slightly unusual type of options uh
for one I I was considering the move C5
which probably isn't great but it's a
resource to always keep in mind idea
being takes takes takes and Bishop G5
but I didn't want to force matters too
much
I was also considering Bishop G5 right
away but after H6 then I'm essentially
committing to trading off the bishop and
I thought my dark Spirit Bishop could be
useful in the long run so instead I
opted for the move 93 here which looks
very strange with the knights in front
of the e-pawn and also blocking the
bishop but the idea is to very quickly
get the Knight to D5
and that's what happened after Bishop E6
I played Knight D5 and then we got to a
position where it's not so easy for
black to
find a useful move because I essentially
have two threats in the position I'm
threatening to take on F6 and then take
on e4 but I'm also threatening to play
Bishop to G5 so let me take a sip of
aloe juice before my throat gets too dry
yeah so my opponent took a bit of a
think here and ultimately decided to
take on D5 with the bishop
and I was really happy to see this move
because after it takes uh 97 C4
I'm able to solidify my Pawn Center and
now it's a situation where I have two
Bishops against two knights and I
thought long term white should be very
much for Choice having the bishop hair
and especially having this diagonal
there's so many situations where white
will dominate the dark sprayers on top
of that E4 could be a weakness
so I thought this was a very nice
opening success but as we're going to
see the struggle is just beginning
he plays my G6 I play Queen D4 Queen E7
B3 uh winning Connect Four but also just
preparing Bishop B2
he plays Queen E5 offering the trade I
defend like Queen and then we trade
Queens
and I was happy to just get a really
solid and controlled position where it
just seems like white already has a
clear advantage and I thought like
gradually I'll either expand on the
queen side or maybe eventually prepare
F3 and get rid of the pawn and then
later F4 and kick around the knights so
yeah I thought the position is just much
easier to play for whites but he plays
my G4
I play Rook E1 so I'm preparing at three
um anticipating the e-file will open he
plays A5 I play F3 we trade and then he
plays like four t five
and then I play rookie three so
everything is going according to plan so
far uh e-files open I'm ready to double
up and create the battery and if I get
just two more moves rookie one and F4
then I'll be winning material well back
does have to be careful here he played
Knight to D7
I double up he takes I take and I'm
feeling good I'm controlling the only
open file in the position
and then he played King f8 and with this
move it looks like he's maybe trying to
play Rook E8 but
um if black plays rookie too soon there
would be Bishop takes G7 tactics where
the king is overworked so uh Black's not
actually threatening to play rookie
eights and for that reason I just keep
making gradual improvements I play Pong
H4 uh then he plays Knight F6 so this is
a sign that maybe he does want to play
rookie 8 very soon
but I keep improving I play King F2 and
I was actually expecting rookie eights
after which I would have uh kept Brooks
on the board I would have gone for Rook
C3 and then maybe prepare the queen side
expansion
but he surprised me here by like
drastically transforming the position
starting with A4 I play B4 and then he
plays A3 and now everything has changed
a bit because
uh there's a big focus on the queen side
for one the a pawn looks a bit weak but
it's hard for me to actually attack it
twice my Bishop would somehow need to
get to C1
and in the meantime because I've
committed my Pawn to B4 uh black now has
a resource to eventually play B5 and try
and just undermine my structure and try
and win the D5 Pawn
so I realized the position isn't
actually so simple and
um I'm not sure if I had anything better
than what I did but I played Rook B3
he played 97
I play Bishop F1 so I'm trying to
discourage B5 but didn't really work
because he played B5 anyway
and uh and yeah I've I was in a
difficult spot here because I wanted to
play C5 but after takes takes he has
Rook B8 and then B4 is hanging and it
seemed like the knights actually
coordinate well and my Bishops aren't
really causing much of a problem for
black
so I took a lot of time
uh I think around here
and ultimately I decided to
concede at least one of my Bishops and
take on F6 so the position transforms
further and the idea was after he takes
back I take he takes I have this move
Bishop to D3
and I thought if anything this is at
least one chance to try and still play
for a win because I'm not only
threatening each Pawn but I'm also a
threatening Bishop E4
so it turns out that black has no time
to defend H7 move like King G7 or H6
just walks into Bishop E4 and white
would be winning so he had to get
counter play and he played what I think
is the best move Rook A4
uh trying to win the B4 Pawn I take on
H7
he took on B4
and here I took on a three
now I will admit I checked very very
briefly with the engine after the game
and I saw the engine said Rook takes E3
was actually a big plunder and I still
don't know why like it seems like the
most natural move like take the pawn and
get another outside pass Pawn but I
think the engine wanted me to take on
before which
it's gonna take a moment for me to
understand why this is so good for white
because A2 is attacked I assume Bishop
B1
and during the game I was thinking about
this but I saw the idea Knight D5
threatening Knight C3
and that's why I didn't go for it
oh wow wow
okay I'm not using the engine but I
think I see why the engine likes us for
white
but I'm not entirely sure
I think
I think white can play King E2 willingly
got forked and after this this this it's
a winning King Pawn ending
but I'm not sure about Knight takes B5
so let me check with engine let's see
what it's saying wow it says White's
winning here King E2 best move can you
choose like the only winning move
willingly getting
triple arguably quadruple Forks
so what's the idea after King D okay so
King D3
Knight takes B5
ah White's winning
probably eventually winning the a pawn
yeah this is a crazy Engine line I would
have had to see in the very end I'll
have Bishop D3 I'll win the a pawn and
then the two outside passers are better
than the two connected passers
um yeah that's that's really difficult
and I didn't mention this but uh during
the game I was really tired like I
didn't have time before the game to get
coffee so I um
yeah I was struggling to like stay
focused and awake but I was able to at
least keep playing moves even if they
weren't the best so I did take on A3
and now the engine does say this is uh
pretty much just equal but as we're
gonna see the game is really just
beginning and uh in epic battle lies
ahead
so he takes on B5 I play G4 I wanted to
make sure that my King has a G3 Square
the event of Rook B2 check he did play
Rook B2 played team G3
and then he goes after my A2 Pawn with
Knight B4
and I can't really defend it so I
counter attack with Rook A7 he takes I
take
and I thought I'm still maybe a little
bit better here just given the structure
and my Bishop should be more useful than
the Knight I do have that past Pawn
that's ready to push and I was imagining
like if I get an H5 and he plays King G7
there's ideas to play Bishop G6 and
there's so many lines where fpan is a
Target because
um yeah it's on the light Square it can
be attacked by the rook and the bishop
so I think he was aware of that he
played rookie two idea of playing Rook
E7 just to neutralize
and then I played Rook 2 B7 initially I
wanted to play Rook D7 and go after this
Pawn but then he would have D5 so I
thought it would be nice to kick the
Knight away
to essentially try and provoke the
Knight to move so if he moves to C6 then
I play this move and D5 just loses a
pawn and rookie 6 also loses a pawn due
to Bishop F5
um so I thought Rook B7 it's like a
clever inclusion
uh but then he plays King G7 counter
attacking my Bishop
I play Bishop E4
I think he plays D5 counter attacking my
Bishop again and when he plays this move
he's accepting the fact that I can go
into a rook ending up a pawn but the
resulting ending uh should be holdable
and we ended up going into it because I
take the knights he takes and I take
and this position it's uh it's three on
two black does have the double F pawns
but I think we were both aware during
the game that
objectively this should be a draw and
it's very very difficult for white to
win but regardless of the situation of
who's playing it always makes sense for
white to play on in such a position and
try and just create as much pressure as
possible and try and create a situation
where black can go wrong so that's what
I was trying to do I was remembering a
game from the the global what was it
called Champions
Global Chess Championship oh the
chess.com Global Championship I forgot
the name but it was in Toronto and there
was a game between nihal sarin and Anish
giri and I'm pretty sure Geary won a
similar type of end game where okay the
maybe two of the pawns were were traded
but he won two on one in some like
amazing way I'm pretty sure it was Geary
it may have been nehal though it could
have been nihal I'll have to find the
clip and overlay it but anyway
um I I did have like a small memory in
mind that's such positions can sometimes
be winnable so for the next so many
moves uh not too much really happens it
was a lot of moving around I was using
the 30 second increment to try and gain
time and trying to to formulate some
type of plan to transform the position
so I think I'll Zoom through pretty
quickly until the next interesting
moment occurs
um we dance I move back
and yeah a lot of Rook dancing
and at some point
I actually allowed a move I didn't
intend to allow this move F5
um
I thought I was just waiting and I was
actually trying to wait until he plays
King G6 so I could play G5 and uh and
win the pawn but um
I think I waited in the wrong manner
because when he plays F5 this is a just
clear way that black can simplify and of
course it makes sense to trade off
double F Pawn for my g-pawn
and here it's really close to just a
very easy draw for buck but I played the
move which I thought still keeps me some
chances Rook to D5 idea being after
takes I Rook G5 check and after takes I
still have an extra Pawn outside pass
Pawn on H file and his King is called
off so I thought maybe there's some
momentum in my direction but it's still
very much a dead draw and actually once
we get to this position if we count the
number of pieces on the board uh there
are seven total so this is already a
table based position and I do have the
table base open I know viewers can't see
it but this is a table based draw I will
say when uh when the valuation changes
if if it does so play continues Rook A5
King G3 Rook A1 King F4 my plan is to
lock the king up and win math pod but it
wasn't so simple he plays Rook A5 Cuts
me off
I played Rook G8 H7 Rook G5 Rook A4 King
G3 King H6 and then F4 so slowly but
surely I'm making a little bit of
progress creating a square on the fourth
rank for my king and eventually I want
to do this this and with the pawn so he
plays Rook A1 King G4
and um yeah at this point he was getting
a little bit lower on time like we can
see the time stamps he's fallen below
four minutes uh he played F6
and I play Rook to B5 now it's still uh
everything is still a draw but I'm I'm
of course trying uh he plays Rook G1 I
play King F5 he plays Rook H1
and I play Rook B8 so creating checking
ideas
he plays King G7 I check he goes back
and then I take and this is really the
best I can hope for from such an end
game whereas king is not on the same
file as my pass Pawn
um of course he takes uh each pawn and
it's still a draw like this is a
theoretical draw but after four hours of
really intense play
it can be easy to have the mind wander
and especially with the time situation
um it's not the easiest type of end game
to hold and I will admit like during the
game I wasn't actually sure of the exact
evaluation like I thought maybe it's
like it's winning for whites but um yeah
the table base still says it's a draw um
because after F5
he plays Rook A4 and there's all these
ideas of checking from a distance and my
king sometimes has a hard time finding
shelter
um because the pawn can't really uh
shift over to the file
so I play King E7
he plays rookie four
king of seven and then he plays King H7
and apparently this is a losing move
and I was aware during the game the king
U7 just didn't seem right uh black is
supposed to just wait with this and even
if I make progress he can keep waiting
and if I Advance he has
Rook A6 F7 and then this this and then
this so apparently this is like the key
way to draw that the king will
eventually come in once I scoot out the
way for the pawn
but that didn't happen
um because he played in H7 and this puts
the King on a very vulnerable square and
gives me the chance to play Rook B1
setting up rook H1 Checkmate or Rook H1
meeting to checkmates and then he has to
uh just not get mated but now I have F6
and I'm ready to play Rook H1 and his
Rook is misplaced like he would like to
start giving checks now but the Rook is
very misplaced on e4 so he plays Rook H4
by Clay Rook G1 at this point I thought
it was going to be an easy one king H7
King f8 just want to keep pushing the
pawn
Rook A4
and then I realized
uh oh his Rook has come back
and he's ready to give checks and if I
play Rook H1
King G6 it's a draw because F7 check
here check
and yeah here he wouldn't take the pawn
because I win The Rook but he can keep
checking and my King has nowhere to hide
so
I was doubting myself when he played
Rook A4 now the position is still
winning and I found the only winning
move here uh feel free to pause the
video if you want to try and find the
only winning move for whites uh but the
move is rookie one
I did play it he plays Rook eight
and here I played a really bad move I
played King F7
um apparently rookie 8 is winning for
white
why is it winning
after this oh there's rookie seven so
what if what if this
F7 wait how is this winning
Rook d8
ah The Rook is creating shelter
and then I'm ready to play this and
queen and what if ah King G6 says this
King here King Yates yeah White's in
time black is not quick enough to play
this and start giving checks
yeah Rook endings are very difficult
um
I I think me and my opponent need to
work on them but anyway let me show what
happens because I play King F7 and now
the position is a draw because of Rook
A7 and he plays Rook A7
I play Rook E7 he plays Rook AIDS
I play Rook D7
he plays Rook b8s it's still a draw
because uh yeah The Rook is cutting me
off I can't move up and if I move my
Rook off the seventh
then he can start giving checks again so
I play Rook A7 and here all black needs
to do is wait with the Rook like any
Rook move along the B file like Rook
here is maybe the the easiest and then
if here there is Rook B here and
basically black can wait until I get the
pawn to F7 and then uh then it's a draw
and if my Rook ever leaves the seven
rank then there will be checks so I hope
that makes sense
sometimes these concepts are still hard
to understand but in this position my
opponent did not wait with a rook he
played King h8
and this gives me the chance
to play Rook back to A3 threatening mate
and after Rook B7
I play King G6 and the black king is
really misplaced in the corner
um because I was running Rook H3 but now
I'm threatening Rook to A8
and there's no defense for black and he
resigned
um it was a crazy finish a lot of plot
twists towards the end
uh the leeches chat was going crazy
because there were so many shifts in the
evaluation uh the engine graph of this
game is
kind of like a roller coaster uh yeah we
can see we can see towards the end here
it was kind of a mess
um so I'll leave a link below if you
want to analyze this game on your own
and try and take away some lessons from
the ending but it was a super long game
I'm really tired uh I did pick up some
dinner I got some Wonton Soup they
messed up my order I asked for
vermicelli noodle salad but I guess I'm
having soup tonight so thanks everyone
for watching really appreciate it if you
made it this far
uh do be sure to check out my twitch
Channel because for the the morning
games uh there will be live commentary
by Jonathan trance so it's twitch.tv
iron Rosen as usual I'll leave all the
links below
and I'll see you guys in the next one
adios